sommes ici en plein désert il tombe dix
centimètres de pluie par an une des
régions les plus arides du monde
[Musique]
voilà pourquoi ce qui pourrait paraître
normal partout ailleurs et juste
aberrant ici
autour des maisons des piscines et de la
végétation copieusement arrosée et plus
de 60 terrains de golf au green bien
vert
et au royaume du gaspillage d'eau
certains vont encore plus loin dans les
folies un peu à l'écart de las vegas une
résidence privée de luxe encore en
construction
c'est là que nous rencontrons robe un
ancien ingénieur des eaux et forêts
aujourd'hui engagé pour la défense de
l'eau
rob veut nous montrer en quoi cette cité
lacustre avec ville à pieds dans l'eau
est insensée à cet endroit même ils ont
créé ce lac artificiel en perdant 16
milliards de litres chaque année nous
avons remettre 8 milliards car la moitié
de l'eau s'est évaporée avec la chaleur
du désert
et tout ça c'est juste pour la
décoration
je pense même que personne ne s'y
baignent vraiment
mais qui vit ici
[Musique]
elle a une maison qu'elle utilise quand
elle vient ici et quand elle part faire
son show elle fait la navette en hélico
entre ici et las vegas
samedi ils détruisent la nature juste
pour une bellevue
une belle vue pour les valeurs que ça
donne en plus à leurs villas et pour
leur propre plaisir donc c'est vraiment
juste un terrain de jeu pour riches et
célèbres
que ce soit les stars du showbiz les
habitants de las vegas où ces millions
de touristes tout le monde oublie juste
l'essentiel
l'eau est ici extrêmement rare et
extrêmement précieuse en fait il n'ya
même qu'un seul trésor à se partager
entre tous le colorado un fleuve qui
traverse l'ouest américain
dans cet immense désert aride
ce mince fil d'eau est l'unique artère
de vie
sa source se trouve en plein coeur des
montagnes rocheuses
c'est cet immense château d'eau glacée
qui en fondant chaque printemps depuis
une éternité s'est frayé un passage à
travers la roche
[Musique]
en y sculptant des reliefs à couper le
souffle
comme le fameux grand canyon
qui donne sur le lac mid tout près de
las vegas
la réserve où la ville vient pomper
massivement son nom sauf qu'aujourd'hui
cette ressource est en danger
même si le barrage hoover retient encore
de l'eau du lac mid la côte d'alerté est
atteint
c'est sur les bords de ce lac que nous
allons nous en rendre compte avec rob ce
défenseur du colorado observe un
phénomène inquiétant depuis quelques
années et sur le lac need il se voit à
l'oeil nu
c'est cette trace blanche sur la roche
alors vous voyez il ya 12 ans l'eau
était en haut de cette race blanche
la trace blanche qu'on voit là bah ouais
ouais là bas sur les falaises
cette bande blanche sur la roche est en
fait un marqueur très simple que rob
relève à chaque passage pour mesurer la
baisse du niveau de l'eau année après
année
cette marque blanche c'est du sel qui
s'est déposé sur la roche quand le lac a
baissé de niveau l'eau s'est évaporée
mais les sels minéraux qu'il ya dans
l'eau eux sont restés sur la paroi donc
on voit très bien jusqu'où le lac est
descendu en à peine 12 ans
cette ligne blanche et c'est un signal
d'urgence
c'est un signal d'alarmé même cela
montre que nous utilisons troll eaux
d'un fleuve qui est si vitale pour 30
millions de personnes
c'est tout le problème
trente millions de personnes dépendent
de l'eau du colorado
alors c'est ville du désert ont pris
conscience qu'un régime sec s'impose
car non seulement las vegas continue de
puiser allégrement dans ce fleuve
colorado
mais surtout cette ville est très loin
d'être la seule à le faire
cet état de l'ouest américain vivant à
son crochet
[Musique]
par tous sur le trajet du fleuve on a
construit des barrages pour retenir
l'eau
et des aqueducs géant pour l'acheminer
là où elle manquait des sortes de paille
monumentale qui aspire le fleuve pour
irriguer des étendues de culture gagner
sur des terres arides
mais surtout pour permettre à d'autres
villes de pousser en plein désert comme
ici à palm springs ou encore là à
phoenix
chaque année dans cette région les
besoins en eau augmentent alors que le
débit du colorado a diminué d'un tiers
suite à des sécheresses continue
résultat les conséquences sont
désastreuses
au fil de son parcours le fleuve se
tarit aujourd'hui il n'aboutit plus que
rarement à la mer
[Musique]
ici dans son ancien delta au mexique il
ne reste qu'une vaste zone le plus
souvent à sécher
un nouveau désert sans vie